Okay, welcome everybody to another Zoom call and number of questions that came in.
If we have room or so if you think of anything, just chat in your question.
All right, let's jump into the questions and said this one in this study.
This study here from PubMed lists five phytochemicals that target cancer stem cells.
I understand that cancer stem cells survive chemo and radiation and are largely responsible for cancer reoccurrence.
And we can add cancer metastasis.
Apparently no FDA approved drugs kill cancer stem cells.
These are the same thing is circulated to ourselves.
And it seems that these phytochemicals are the best way of dealing with cancer stem cells.
They're curcumin, EGCG, which is the cancun from green tea extract.
So four of ane resmeratrol and jettestime.
Shouldn't I be taking all of these at least since there are more like pectosol C and such.
What are high quality products in your store that fulfill this?
Does cancer stem cells are circulated to our cells render?
Concerned for high blood levels of other circulating tumor cells mute.
Why does standard oncology not seem to be concerned with cancer stem cells?
Well, it's the first question or the last question first standard oncology does not seem to be concerned with circulated tumor cells or cancer stem cells.
Because they don't have a protocol for it.
It's the only thing I can think of.
They just don't. They don't.
Try to prevent metastasis store prevent disease every matter of fact you go in and you talk to your oncologist.
And I think everybody probably had a similar experience where they said diet was no not important supplements were not important lifestyle is not important.
Just let me take care of this cancer with surgery.
They keep a radiation or behavioral therapy and that's they just treat disease that way so they just follow the protocol in their on their computer manual.
So yes, could a person be taking all of these? Yes, is there anything wrong with that?
First of all, I would say the genestine one is from mainly from a study of ovarian cancer.
And I don't think the genestine has as much significance for circulating tumor cells as for much other than the than ovarian, but that's another point of discussion.
But there, but there are a lot.
These are mainly except for a sole favorite. EGC, curcumin, respiratory, quercetin, these are anti-inflammatories. So they don't necessarily destroy circulating tumor cells.
But they help your body with any inflammatory process. So, you know, the flaminolates in general are good.
Should everybody be taking these?
Well, yes and no. I mean, the reason why we do the cheek swab test is to test for what would be best for you so that you're not taking way too many things.
Now, are some things like these things bad to take?
Are they hard at your liver if you don't nest? If they're not necessarily doing anything for you.
Yes and no, I've had people take, you know, to high doses of curcumin for a long period of time and develop antibodies because they have such gut issues that they end up developing antibodies to turmeric.
So, I mean, it is possible that you can develop an anti, antibodies to different things and then you, you have a sensitivity to them. So becomes inflammatory and anti-inflammatory.
So that is possible. I have this question come up in different forms all the time. I heard this is good. I read this article. Can I take this too?
Yeah, we could, you could and you, and you may do whatever you feel like you should do whatever you feel like God is leading you to do. God, you feel like God put this article in front of me.
I really feel I should take some of these. Then you certainly have every right to do that. I'm just trying to help you not take too many things.
You do, you know, I know there's a lot of, I mean, I have some people come to me and they're on literally, you know, people on over 150 different supplements.
I mean, it just is counterintuitive to me that, you know, you take too many things and you can overwhelm your liver, you can overwhelm your detoxification pathways.
If you absorb these things and your body can't use them, they have to go out of your body somehow and they have to use your detox ordals and that can be overwhelming to your body. So I don't always think just because there's a study that shows that it's good for, that it could be good for me that everybody should be taking it, but I also don't think that you, you can't, if you feel led to do some.
Hopefully, that's exactly the question. Recently, I received a brand, a new brand or bodily of curcumin. So I think he's talking about the curcuclear here.
So our curcuclear, I upgraded it. So whatever I find because there's, there's new information coming out about supplements and sometimes there's, you know, a, you know, a greater bioavailability with, with a different supplement.
So then I change it. So anybody that's a bed with me for any period of time, know that. So I changed our curcuclear once ago to this newer curcumin that is more bioavailable.
So that's why I changed the curcuclear. You also noticed that I changed the Burberry. We still have the Burberry clear, but now we also have the Burberry clear pro that I've changed all of our cancer patients over to the Burberry clear pro. It's five times more bioavailable.
It's a new DHB Burberry that just came out and literally only a couple of companies carry it. And we got it and we private label that so we call that the Burberry clear pro.
So we changed that 80k a few years ago, we change, I mean, there's any time there's something new we want to at least, you know, expect that if this is going to be a better product for people.
And it's better for the money.
We're able to provide the new curcuclear at the same price as the old one, even though costs us more money. Same thing with the Burberry clear grow costs us more money, but we're provided the same price.
So hopefully that helps us to spend proven to be more bioavailable.
On the night 11, Zoom call you answered someone that they might want to get a mastectomy, which surprised me because initially you said you didn't believe in reconstructive surgery.
I know that's two different things, but isn't it true that cutting into cancer may spread it?
So let's answer that question. So it surprised you that I may suggest someone do a mastectomy, a lumpectomy or chemotherapy or immunotherapy.
I don't, I mean, you haven't listened to me for very long because I and I try to be insulted, but I'm just trying to say that I am very open minded to what's best for each person.
So it's everybody's an individual and I think it's wrong and I've said this maybe 5,000 times to I think it's very wrong to take a dogmatic stance on things like this.
There's things that you take a dogmatic stance on but health care things mostly you have to be open minded.
So I'm not against doing a mastectomy if that's the right thing for that person.
I know some people that they're just will not do it because it's not right for them, but I also know some people that won't do it because they're so dogmatically positioned or angry against the medical field for some reason.
That's not necessarily healthy either. We have to be open minded to hey is maybe it's time to debug a cancer.
So can surgery increase growth factors? Yes, surgery of any kind can increase growth factor.
What I say I'm against reconstructive surgery, it's because that's a very elective surgery.
Now again, I'm only against it in principle. I know there's a lot of women that will have their breast removed but they'll have reconstructive therapy because also emotionally tied to having a breast and I understand I can't fully understand it.
I'm not a woman, but I can understand that your emotions are equally as important in your health recovery is anything else.
You are a whole person. Some other women will be forget it. I get it removed. I get it.
You know, that's probably healthier, not doing elected surgeries that will increase growth factors is probably a smarter idea.
But everybody's gone away that old as well as far as a mastectomy, you're debulking a tumor. So I've never been against debulking a tumor.
Now that is surgery and it's going to increase growth factor, but there's a huge benefit to debulking a tumor.
So if you have a giant mast in your colon, number one, it could block the lumen and cause back up and an emergency surgery situation.
But just debulking it decreases the amount of energy that your immune system needs to do to expand to kill the cancer.
So if I have a three centimeter round mass in my breast, develop an energy that my immune system has to put out to try to kill every that all those cells and to stop that growth is tremendous.
If that could be removed now by immune system, could maybe expand its energy on like circulating tumor cells.
And you know, these cancer stem cells and where there could be metastasis and not be as involved with dealing with this mass.
So it can be very beneficial to debulking a cancer.
Of course, there's risks, especially brain surgery and things like that. And there's times when it's not important to do that.
But everybody's different, every case is different.
Finish up this question. I have a breast that is slowly over one and a half years being eaten away with a huge disgusting scam on it.
When I asked the oncologist about it, they said it would continue to eat away. Well, that's that's a person's one person's opinion.
It could certainly stop too. Does this mean I need to have surgery to remove it?
Not necessarily we have patients that it eats away and it just stops and they end up with the scam but they still live 10 years later.
So everybody's different. So you have to weigh all those things out. So you weigh out everybody's opinion.
This doctor obviously thinks that you should do a mastectomy. I think probably.
I would say you that if that's an option from a surgeon's standpoint, that is an option for you.
But just debulking a cancer remember doesn't remute doesn't mean you've removed all the cancer stem cells.
It absolutely doesn't mean you removed all the cancer stem cells are circulated tumor cells.
So it doesn't mean that you've completely solved your problem.
So if I have a little lump in my breast and I go and I remove both my breasts doesn't mean no, I don't have breast cancer anymore.
Well, you know, it means that you debolt that breast cancer.
You certainly have circulated tumor cells in your body long before you ever discovered that you had cancer.
So while it was still two million cells large, it was giving off circulated tumor cells and it was not even discoverable at that size.
So it's not that you're solving your problem completely, but you're debulking a mask that would be the advantage of doing surgery.
But again, I'm not saying everybody has to do surgery. We have lots of patients that have never done surgery on their cancers.
And they're still going today. So everybody is different.
Will it continue to eat away by body or eventually stop? Well, nobody can honestly answer that question.
Because nobody knows the future. So the oncologist is giving his opinion has he ever seen anybody that has not done what he asked to do, which is surgery.
And that would be a question that you can ask that oncologist. I don't know if they'll give you an honest answer.
We've seen people not get surgery and it stopped eating away and it stops and they're still alive today.
We've seen people it didn't stop and they ended up passing away.
We've had people get mastectomies and pass away and have mastectomies and live a long, happy life.
And it's just, you can't say one way or the other. You can't say dog medically. Everybody needs to do this or everybody needs to do that. You can't do that.
You know, you can, but you'd be lying. That's just not honest. So I refuse to not be honest just to play Kate people or to push my agenda. I think that's just wrong.
You don't put anything topically on its comfortable wear fake breast on top of it because it oozes you know, syramed at times, which I think is good because it's you're getting out dead.
Sounds that way. I know you're going to say that it's up to me, but I really don't want to have surgery. Okay, well, you know, again, I think you need to just like everything else in our life, we need to pray about it with an open mind.
In your prayer should be something like, Lord, I don't you know, I don't want to do surgery. But if you want me to do surgery, I'm open to your will be done.
So change my heart, change my mind, change my heart of this. There's no Bible verse that says thou shalt not do surgery.
Though there is one saying thou shalt do surgery when the surgeon tells you you should do surgery and they are God and you need to do what they tell you to do.
There's nothing on it. It's dependent upon our relationship with him to know what to do in certain situations.
We can't have all our answers in black and white. There's a reason, oh, I wish I could, I wish it was just already know what to do.
No, you don't. Then you would need a relationship with a living God. You're worth to have a relationship with a living God and he knows our heart.
And to speak to him that way, God, I do not want to have surgery. I know I do not want to have surgery. But if you want me to have surgery and this is what you want me to do to save my life or for whatever reason, then I'll be open to it.
Change my heart, change my mind, you know, work on my heart. I'll be open to it. That's how I pray for these things and how I'd suggest you to do so too.
Our medicinal mushrooms good for everyone. Well, that kind of goes back to this question here. You know, are these things good for everyone?
Again, I don't think these things are bad for really anybody unless you have a sensitivity to one of these things.
So in general, I don't think these things are bad for anybody. Are medicinal mushrooms bad for anybody? Well, I guess the only caveat to that would be if you have brain cancer, you don't want, you don't want to use lions made.
Lions made mushroom helps is a neuro generative muscle mushroom so it helps stimulate neuro generation, which you don't want if you have brain tumor or brain cancer.
So I guess that would be the only caveat to that. But just like anything does everybody need medicinal mushrooms? No, I don't think so. So again, more things that you take, your body has to detoxify them.
So you just got to weigh that out too. If I send you my labs, do you look at them and decide if we need to talk about them?
I want you to send me your labs, send us your labs so that we can get them in your folder, but no, I'm not going to, I just don't have time to look at everybody's labs and then decide if we need to talk to them.
I mean, that takes, you know, anywhere from 10 to 30 minutes to really look at everybody's lab, sometimes it could take longer than if I could period to pass labs.
You're going to have to make that decision because if I did order those labs specifically, then, you know, you're getting those labs out of you're going to have to make that decision whether you want to speak with me.
So on the rare occasion that I have time and I do look at somebody's labs is probably somebody listen to this and well, you called and said you wanted to talk to me after that after you looked at my lab.
There's times that I do have time and I look at them, but it's not usually I don't. So it just gets put in your file.
So it is ultimately your responsibility to hey, I need to talk to them about my labs.
So otherwise it's just I don't have enough time in the day to do that. Sorry.
I really prayed about the bed is all protocol. Are there any negatives to try it or can I just add it to my current supplement protocol?
So again, I test everybody on this. So if I, you know, if I didn't recommend it.
Again, if you feel like I'm leading you to do this fan bed protocol, can it be something you can try?
Okay, so in general, the fan bed protocol is not going to interfere with any any current protocol you're doing except there's a caveat.
So fan bed is always a drug and fan bed is all I mean, we've been using fan bed is on having people on fan bed is all for, you know, quite a few years now.
And I'll be the first to tell you that there are some side effects to it that you have to keep an eye on it.
You have to, you have to be doing a complete metabolic protocol, a complete metabolic panel blood test on a very regular basis if you're going to do fan bed is all.
Because fan bed is all can be hard on your liver and you can get an elevation of STLT and alkaline phosphatase.
And if that goes up and if that spikes up, that's inflammation in your liver and you could damage your liver.
You got to go off a fan bed is all for a period of time till those numbers call back down and then you can do it again.
So fan bed is all is not like like adding mushrooms or adding curcumin or adding, you know, residential or something like that.
This is a drug and it can be hard on your liver.
Typically none of these things if you added any of these things are going to be hard on your liver, okay.
Adding mushrooms are not going to be hard on your liver and cause you any issues, but any fan bed is all to your protocol can be hard on your liver.
And we have a lot of people that hasn't done anything to their liver.
We have some people that have caused upset tummy and they just started taking it with food and that solve that problem.
But you have to be willing to do a complete metabolic panel which measures ALT, AST and alkaline phosphatase.
At a very regular basis like at least once a month if you're going to do a fan bed is all otherwise I don't think you should be doing it because you couldn't have put liver inflammation.
I just think you got to be careful.
I got all the circulating stem cell info from Dr. Ralph boss boss and it's part of his new boss method or something like that.
He says it's pretty clear in the research that circulating stem cells is a significant issue.
Stem cells is not an alternative issue.
It's well-established and makes me wonder since circulated tumor cells are different than cancer stem cells or so I understand why I'm so advised to do chemo if it doesn't stop or kill stem cells.
Yes, chemo can shrink any small yet not detectable cell families, but also targeting stem cells can supposedly do the same thing.
Of course, this is an labense perspective.
Yeah, ask that question to your oncologist and probably get pencil slapped or something like that.
It's true and then the other negative is going on in your case, you're you're debunked your cancer.
There's no evidence of disease in the cancer and they want you to go on a protocol of chemo therapy.
The other flip side of that is chemo therapy is going to diminish your immune response.
So the catch 22 with chemo therapy, it's going to really diminish your white blood cell code, which is going to include your natural killer cells and the lymphocyte line that kill circulate tumor cells.
So it's just it's just it's just it's just bothersome and they just and you and you mentioned to them while circulate tumor cells cancer stem cells are going to be, you know, those are what I need to kill and chemo therapy doesn't kill them.
They're just giving you a blank stare. So, you know, again, you know, in a case like that, I prior would be the same.
It's like, or this does not make any sense to me either you have to make it make sense to me and really give me peace about following the oncologist protocol here.
So we are called mimically to use wisdom and what is wisdom but application of knowledge.
So we we have to gain knowledge and you're the first one to look up studies, look up things trying to learn from as many different people as possible.
And then you try to apply that as best as you possibly can. And when you try to apply the information from your oncologist, it just it doesn't make a lot of sense.
And I'm with you. A lot of people are with you. I think the people that just blindly follow what their oncologist tells them to do,
hitter themselves in a lot of different ways. You're just giving over your personal power to somebody else.
And I think it takes a lot of your your your bodily autonomy away and your energy away from killing cancer.
And I don't think those people have as good outcomes.
So even if you through all your studies decided, yep, I got to do X amount of rounds of chemotherapy that I'm going to stop.
At least you're making that decision based upon all the knowledge that you have and you're asking God to now convert that to wisdom, which means how to use that knowledge.
I think that's the right thing to do. So you're right. I mean, the test is this is circulated to ourselves that are setting up home to raise a family.
Those are cancer stem cells. They're in a location now and have the ability to start replicated rapidly to fighting what cancer is the only thing that can keep that at bay is your immune system.
And when you talk about these things in this study that have shown to diminish cancer stem cells, it's because the effect that these things have on your immune system and on a general inflammation.
So yeah, it's interesting that these studies tend to get buried. I refer to, you know, the studies on neural inflammation, where billions and millions and millions of dollars was poured into neural inflammation, brain inflammation, post conclusive syndrome, when all that hug blew was going on about the NFL players and all the lawsuits with NFL players.
Post retirement, we're having all sorts of neurological issues, you know, increase incidence of Parkinson's. Did you hear Brett par was just dying just came out with his diagnosis Parkinson's. I knew something was not because he had an interview about six months ago, saying he would never let any of his kids or grandkids play football. And they said, what do you mean play football like not in the college level.
And no, not in the high school level or the grade school level at all because he did hit at all in the head increases your neural inflammation.
Oh, he must be going to a functional neurologist, it sure enough, he's come out with the diagnosis Parkinson's from post conclusive syndrome from neural inflammation.
Well, I'm bringing that up because all the studies and all the money that was pumped into that one drug decreases neural inflammation. What do they find? The only thing that decreases it.
It's the only thing that helped. So you want to increase your life and live a long life, even if you weren't dealing with post cancer, these things definitely are your best bet.
I think so, four of eight again would shine would be more for certainly stem cells and cancer stem cells for the tumors that are more hormonal a driven like genostate, but recent CEA test went and I saw that too and went up again, which got my attention to say the least regard.
What is it three months post surgery? The interesting to see when that starts to go down now. Any other questions. All right, well, thank you guys for a great zoom call and we will be back next week on plus you too.
I'll be praying for you and the person who asked this question about their breast, please everybody be praying for this person that God gives them wisdom and peace about their situation.
That's the other part that should be having it God gives you peace and passes all understanding that you're not influenced by somebody you don't want to be influenced by because that can be something I could not.
I'll be praying for all you and we'll see you next week. Bye bye.